[拍手]
11歳の夏
私は生まれて初めて一人で飛行機に乗っていました
小学校6年生から高校冊卒業までの間
ハワイ島で単身留学するためです
これ私の学校なんです
親から離れるの近衛長い期間特に初めてだったので私は緊張するどころかとっても
ワクワクしていました
親がいないなんて最高
銀髪のジャスティンビーバーみたいな彼氏できるかなと思っていました
ですが
実際は
最初の1カ月はそれまでの人生で最も辛い毎日でした
英語が全く喋れなかった私は
助けての声も出せずに
毎日泣いてばかりいました
なんでお母さん私のことこんなところに一人で送ったんだろう
私もなんで行きたいって言っちゃったんだろう
そう思っていました
私は強かったのです
英語を喋れない私のことをクラスのみんなが何でこのここにいるのと思ってるに違い
ないと思っていました
実際私のことを必要ないと思ったのか
クラスではまるでいないかのように振る舞われることもありました
そんなとき
私に声をかけてくれたのは金髪の彼氏ではなく
れいめいたのクレアでした
彼女は勉強の時も食事の時も移動の時もいつも私のそばにいで助けてくれました
彼女との絆は家族以上に強い存在で結ばれました
この絆を切り口に私は徐々に自分の意見を相手に伝えることができるようになりました
寂しい辛いといった気持ちも素直に伝えられる
そんなはが広がりました
こういった見えない痛みを心から許せる相手と分かち合い
お互いを支え合うために必要なのは絆をはじめとしたコミュニティです
声をかけること
そして何よりもかけられることを一人では自分は生きられない弱い人間なんだと端に
思わずに受け入れることです
この経験を経て無事に高校を卒業し
そして日本に大学入学のために帰国した私は就活を始めました
そこでこんな経験をしました
インターンシップ中男性上司が
女性はすぐ妊娠すると会社辞めるから採用に困るんだよね
他の男性と談笑しているのを聞きました
私は耳を疑いました
これからキャリアも家庭も持つかもしれない私の前でそんなこと言うの
と思いました
この事について友達や先輩に相談すると表向きには女性活躍と就活で歌いながらも
実際はこういった隠れた偏見が毎日行われていることに気づかされました
例えば私の前場合は男性上司から俺のモチベーションを上げるためにもうにてぃ
スカート履いてよと言われたり
女性は客寄せパンダだから一蹴されたり信じられませんよね
でも実際に起きていることなんです
ですがこういったことを心は許せる人と話し合ったりする機会が少ないとなかなか表に
出すことは難しいですよね
私もそうでした
ですがハワイの体験でコミュニティの力について知っていた私は女性が一歩踏み出す
ことを後押しする
dean サークルに参加しました
議員
一歩を踏み出せ
これは facebook 使用を務めるシェリルサンドバーグ氏が執筆した方も元に
設立された団体です
この活動を通して私はたっくさんのパワフルな女性たちに出会うことができました
一方デー
活動を続けているうちに私の中である疑問が生まれました
林員を立ち上げて facebook のしようよおーまで勤めるような
シェリルサンドバーグのように自分次第でどんどん頑張れる環境にいる女性はそもそも
どのくらいいるのでしょうか
自分次第で頑張れば何でもできるよよく言われますよね
一歩踏み出せばいいじゃん
ですがそんなに簡単なことでしょうか
私は範囲にいた時一人では全くがんばれる気はありませんでした
何を頑張ればいいのかもわかりません
でもそんな中でも一歩踏み出せたのは
側に理解してくれる人がいたからです
そこで私はこの隠れた変形についてもっとオープンに話し合うコミュニティを作るため
に大学4年生で
輪院はセガを設立しました
これは男らしさや女らしさといった
もっと日常的な偏見について学生同士でカジュアルにディスカッションすることで
みんなで一緒に考えて一歩踏み出そうというメッセージを届け6
たものです
このコミュニティを通じてさまざまな変化が起きました
ある女子大生が就活で自分の気持ちにもっと素直に向き合えることができるようになり
ました
またある学生はリーダーという言葉をこれまで嫌煙していたのですがこのコミュニティ
に参加することによって自ら
イベントやリーダーシップをどんどん取るようになっていきました
さらに私の中にも変化がありました
同じ信念を持つ人同士をつなげそして自分自身も積極的につながっていくことでもっと
力強く声を上げることができるようになりました
見えない痛みを分かち合うために必要なのは
声をかけることそしてなによりも声を掛けられることを恥だとは思わずに受け入れる
ことです
無理に大きなコミュニティに参加する必要ありません
信頼できるまた一人を見つければいいのです
それが私にとってくれあだったように
みなさんはもうこのコミュニティの一部です
次は皆さんが声をかけそして買うかけられる番です
そしてみんなで勇気を出して一歩踏み出しましょうありがとうございました
[拍手]